what's the future really going to be it
seems like it's VR and air okay let's
pivot the entire ship
and commit to that future huge move just
the whole thing yeah and we have enough
money to pour into this that even if
you're not really sure if you're a
skeptic if you're on the edges we'll
pour money into whatever you were you
know hesitant about to make it good
enough for it to be the future
and then when we have this like
foundation of the internet 2.0 which is
this metaverse that they're imagining
people spend lots of time in then Apple
can't screw them over or Google can't
take the upper hand because they sell
all the ads it'll be the Facebook
dominated thing
and that would suck because one company
dominating the entire internet and
having control over the whole Foundation
of what we're all doing online is a
terrible idea yeah yeah but
that's their Vision that's their
competitive ah so they're limited now
and they're like let's get ahead of this
so that they can't live I think they see
the trajectory of of facebook.com going
like this yeah and they have infinite
dollars to just look for the next thing
and fully commit to it and what do you
think of that bet
um I I think it's really interesting so
I've seen some really cool demos of like
things that work really well there's a
quest Pro headset that I got to try
which is like it has this pass-through
mode and it'll track your computer and
you're paired your computer so you put
it on and it still shows you your entire
environment but then your computer on
the desk three more monitors will pop
out of it and you get to use it just
like a normal computer wow and like the
tech it's a little bit glitchy it's a
little buggy it's not the sharpest thing
in the world but like this idea of like
I have three monitors in front of me in
this little train wherever I want to go
just bring the headset with me is like
I get why they think that's the future
and they're going to pour billions and
billions of dollars into that until it's
great
oh sorry real quick I have one uh I
don't want to call it like a criticism
but one thing I noticed I got the
goggles right my wife and I have them
the question this is uh you're just one
of the VR headsets I think we have
Oculus I think Oculus Quest yeah man now
the meta Quest because they bought them
too right uh so and my wife hated it I'm
loving it I'm watching like climbing
videos it's me and Alex Arnold and I'm
just looking down I'm like it's
terrifying whatever but what an
interesting thing happened which is
different than like watching a TV or a
basketball game and zoning out or like
playing video games and kind of zoning
out it completely isolates you from your
partner the goggles do yeah and I think
that there's a hiccup there that they're
not noticing which is you can have a
headset on playing Call of Duty and your
wife's over there but you can still talk
about what you need to do that day and
the things you need to go get and do you
like this outfit do you like this should
we go here once those [ __ ] goggles go
on you're in a different world literally
and that's the point but it's gonna
there's gonna be friction relationship
wise
so there's the idea of the metaverse
we're all putting on headsets and we're
in there together she doesn't buy in to
climbing with Alex Arnold like me yeah
or surfing at jaws with shandorian
and kailani you know if she's in doing
her thing right now we're not in the
world together and we're not spending
that like time together a couple do this
a lot where it's like we're doing
something together we might not be
talking and I think that there's going
to be some friction with that they have
to figure that out so this is so there's
two there's two things I keep saying
which is VR and AR VR virtual reality is
you put the headset on and you're
immersed in a different world which is
what you're talking about AR a little
bit different is taking the reality
around you and augmenting it a little
bit augmented reality add a screen to
the wall add the weather you're talking
about the two other screens yes so right
now in 2022 the tech that we have is you
putting a big ass headset on and being
isolated from the world I think meta's
idea is if we put enough money into this
it miniaturizes over and over and over
again it's got cameras it's got sensors
suddenly looks like I'm just wearing
glasses I see the whole world but I also
get the VR experience the AR experience
is everywhere and maybe that's possible
so the Oculus is like the first cell
phone exactly we look
is absurd I don't want to carry this
thing everywhere there's no future to
this brick in my car but if I'm folding
it throwing in my jacket suddenly it
makes sense and imagine whoever Nokia
had been working on the cell phone for
50 years right before anybody else
started right yeah is it avoidable that
meta takes over the metaverse completely
so I think there's a couple other
companies that have enough money and
enough foresight to start to compete I
think everyone expects Apple to have a
headset in the next year I think we're
going to see that and they're great at
Hardware Apple's great at hardware and
they're great at ecosystem so you better
believe they're worried about like
everyone who has an iPhone is going to
want the Apple headset not the other
headset and apple just like they do with
the bubbles there will be Apple's
headset and the others yeah right yeah
that's the thing you can expect
Google you know they've got the money
and the tech and software creating
others oh yeah we talk about this all
the time the ecosystem and the walls
that they build the figurative walls
that's iMessage FaceTime all that
charger right it's like if you have an
Apple charger yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so yeah I think there's a couple
companies close that are about to do
some stuff but meta is the one that's
like at the top of the mountain yelling
about the future that we all see yeah so
but it feels like we're not exactly
buying in just yet I like what you
described about just the regular glasses
that you put on yeah I think that would
be really interesting do you think
people worship with Ray-Ban did you see
those oh that's like your normal weight
they just look like that's cool together
like at both ends of it there's like the
Oculus then there's the ray bands which
is like just a camera yeah they're like
we get this closer to Oculus we get
Oculus closer to this then we're good we
get something good in the middle and do
you see people wearing them at all times
like how does the regular interaction
work outside of like the workspace yeah
I think so apple or sorry meta would
like us to all just have them on like
all day they want people to work in the
metaverse still want people to
collaborate and meet and hang out with
friends in the metaverse and everyone's
got their headsets on all the time
you've seen Ready Player one yeah
that is what you think the future is
yeah it that's the that's the future I
keep picturing whenever they describe
how much time they want us to spend with
the headsets on it seems dystopian right
I think though we still have to think of
how much smaller and less uh immersive
the headsets can be I think we'll we'll
get these crazy weird Wally moments
where we're like I don't want to have
this headset on all day this reminds me
of a dystopian future I don't like but
if the tech gets good enough and small
enough and it is just like you can hit a
button on your glasses and it turns on
and then it goes away and it's like a
cool thing you can have then people will
be more willing to give it a shot and
use it sometimes I think they want us to
spend all day in it though yeah because
that's tough when you think of your
phone time your screen time is a lot of
screen time seven eight six hours nine
hours a day yeah imagine augmenting it
where I don't even this is a better
reality than what I'm in that's why I
don't do the Apple watch all these guys
have the Apple watch but it keeps me off
my phone actually same thing yeah
take your phone out less well but it
drops but you're looking at this all day
not all day just when I get a text what
happens a lot of times when I get a text
personally I look at the text and then
oh I'm in a warm hole of other things I
can look at oh now let's check Instagram
because it's already open that barrier
is so much smaller so if you have the
watch on that's like a barrier you don't
take your phone out of your pocket I get
it I get a text I check it I don't reply
it's over and then you don't scroll and
I don't because if I take my I get the
message I feel the vibration I take the
phone on my pocket
do a thing for her right and she has to
do this every single time she goes
Andrew could you ask about that thing I
take out my phone and then 30 seconds
later she goes did you ask about the
thing and I'm on like Brazzers or
something yeah I'm asking about it yeah
but it's so true you're in a wormhole
yeah it is and I didn't notice how
sucked in I was without even realizing
like how secondary the movements were
until I put the time limit things on and
I knew that it was limited yeah but my
my thumb would just naturally go and
click on this is that crazy yeah that's
crazy my thumb is just has a mind of
myself it's not my fault you like
memorize exactly where the icons are on
your home screen it's just there you
don't even think about it yeah yeah
there's these there's these folding
phones now these flip phones where it's
like that little extra barrier of like
you know there's a screen on the outside
but then you open it and it's the whole
phone so you use you don't open it but
you get the texting you see it on the
outside and then you just dismiss it and
don't open the phone because the second
you open the phone you're in over it's
in and was that their idea they want to
reduce the amount of time I don't think
that's the primary I think it's just a
Cool Tech that's one of the things I
noticed when using a folding phone is I
started using my phone less or at least
getting wasting time hours in less so
how do you do less phone time how do you
get caught or stop yourself from getting
caught up in the scroll personally yeah
uh my goal my only thing that I've
started doing like a few months ago is I
start my day without my phone so I think
it's easy to just endlessly scroll and
then I get like existential about it I
zoom out and I just like see myself on
the couch just like doing nothing that
sucks so I I like getting out of bed
feet on the ground start the day without
touching the phone yeah my watch wakes
me up actually it just like Taps me on
the wrist and I just go all right time
to get up because as soon as I like take
the phone off hit the alarm stop button
suddenly I'm right where I was gonna be
with this so I that's my thing that I
think works kind of well it's really
hard at night to like
because I I have this I want to get
through all my notifications and emails
and everything before I put it down yeah
and so I'm like sitting in bed finishing
up and then suddenly I'm scrolling and I
forgot that I was just about to sleep
yeah that's that part sucks but that's
what how long in the morning without the
phone
uh just to like get downstairs to like
start my day
can I ask if you had to guess your
average screen time because it's easy to
say it's part of my job yes yeah I do
that my job is a [ __ ] excuse to
ourselves on the internet yeah yeah no
it's a lot it's like seven hours a day
yeah it has to be do you think um I know
when Google Glass launched and also with
the Ray-Bans like the biggest thing for
me was like it's one thing to tap into
virtual world it's another thing to be
pointing a camera at someone else's face
and I think like get the [ __ ] out of my
face and that camera is the thing that I
think a lot of people that'll be a big
pushback yo that's a great Point how it
affects social interactions when people
constantly think that they're being
recorded yeah yeah that would make me
incredibly uncomfortable yeah it was a
and Google Glasses 2012. yeah remember
the camera is on your face in 2012.
yeah and I was in college at the time
and I even had a pair of them and I was
like all right time to give this you
know possible future a shot and I'm like
I walk into class with this one I'm like
I hate myself
and stuff like we have so many good
videos yeah what's up guys that clip was
brought to you by rocket money okay this
is the personal finance app that allows
you to manage subscriptions lower bills
build a custom budget and grow your
savings all in one place that's right
they're canceling unwanted subscriptions
for you safely and secure you don't even
got to call up a company they got your
back they're low in your bills they're
literally negotiating your bills for you
all you gotta do is send them a picture
of the build Tap a button and they got
your back and monitoring your credit
card score and much more so if you're
ready to save some money go to
rocketmoney.com flagrant or click the
link in the description below to get
started for free or unlock even more
features with premium that's
rocketmoney.com flagrant to get started
for free click the link in below